So here you go.
This is from the wonderlic people there,
a commercial company that makes general
cognitive ability tests and it's often
used by corporations even though it's
actually illegal,
it's actually illegal to use Iq tests,
but the wonderlic doesn't promote
themselves as testing Iq.
I think they think it's general
cognitive ability,
which is the same thing,
but whatever the sats,
the Gres,
the lsats,
all of those are Iq tests.
So now they're more crystallized than
fluid and we'll get to that in a minute.
But crystallized knowledge is what you
accrue across type.
So you could say that fluid intelligence
is what programs your brain,
it fills it with facts.
Let's say it fills it with knowledge and
then.
But you can get an estimate of your
intelligence by sampling your domain of
factual knowledge.
And the reason for that is that while
obviously the better the programmer,
the better the content.
And so what that also means is that you
can,
you could,
if you were prefrontal cortex was
damaged later in life,
your fluid Iq could plummet,
but you're crystallized.
Iq remain more or less intact.
So even though they're not different,
one produces the other and then once the
producer has produced,
then the producer can disappear and you
still got the uncoated knowledge.
So at least that's how it looks to me.
So.
Okay.
So how smart do you have to be to be
different things in life?
Well,
if you have an Iq of 100,
16 to 130,
which is 85th percentile and above.
So it's one person in eight up to one
person in 1:30,
I believe is 85,
90 95.
Is it 95?
90 five.
One person a to one person in 20.
Then you can be a attorney,
a research analyst and editor and
advertising manager,
a chemist,
an engineer and executive manager,
et Cetera.
That's,
that's the,
that's not the high end for ICU by the
way.
You know that it can go up.
Well,
it can go up indefinitely,
although there's fewer and fewer people
as it goes up.
So if you want to be the best at what
you're doing,
bar none,
then having an Iq of above 145 is a
necessity.
And maybe you're pushing one 60 in some
situations and maybe that's me.
Make a new one person in 10,000
or even one person in 100,000.
And then also to really be good at it,
you probably have to be reasonably
stress tolerant and also somewhat
conscientious.
So people you think,
well why is it that smart people are at
the top of dominance hierarchies?
And the answer to that in part is
because they get their first,
right.
I mean everything's a race roughly
speaking.
And the faster you are,
the more likely you are to be at the
forefront of the pack.
And intelligence in large part is speed.
That's not all of it is.
So if you're moving towards something
difficult rapidly,
the faster people are going to get there
first.
So Iq of 1:15,
1:10
to 1:15,
so that's 80,
fifth to 73rd,
85th percentile.
Copywriter,
accountant,
manager,
sales manager,
sales analysts,
manager,
person,
purchasing agent,
registered nurse,
sales account executive.
If you look at universities,
the smartest people are,
they're above this.
Who are the smartest people at
University?
What do you think?
Mathematicians,
physicists,
and mathematicians.
Right?
Right.
I can tell you who's on the other end,
but I won't.
Yeah,
I'd like to though.
Anyway.
Anyways.
Okay.
Going down the wondering three to one,
a way to slightly above average,
right?
Sixtieth to 70th percentile,
store manager,
bookkeeper,
credit clerk,
lab test,
or general sales,
telephone sales,
accounting clerk,
computer operator,
customer service Rep,
technician,
clerk,
typist.
So you see at this level people are.
People have some technical skill and
some ability to deal with complex
things.
Okay.
That's dead.
Average hundred is average dispatcher in
a general office.
Police patrol officer,
receptionist,
cashier,
general clerical inside sales clerk
meter reader,
printer teller,
data entry,
electrical helper,
95th to 98 machinists,
food partner manager,
quality control checkers,
security guard,
unskilled labor maintenance,
arc,
welder,
die setter mechanic.
Good,
good Iq range for relatively qualified
tradespeople.
80 seven to 93 messenger,
factory production worker Assembler,
food service worker,
nurses aid,
warehouseman,
custodian,
janitor,
material handler,
packer.
Now what you're seeing,
what you're starting to see is that as
you move down the hierarchy,
the jobs get simpler.
They're more likely to be assigned by
other people or the repetitive because
what Iq predicts to some degree is how
rapidly you can learn something,
but once you've learned it,
it doesn't predict how necessarily how
well you do at it,
and so the more repetitive jobs tend,
people with lower iqs are more suited to
more repetitive jobs under 87.
Is there something?
Well,
no,
right,
that's a big problem and it's something
our society has not addressed at all.
Jobs for people with Iqs of less than 85
are very,
very rare.
So what the hell are those people
supposed to do?
It's like one,
it's 15 percent of the population.
What are they supposed to do?
Well,
we better figure it out because one of
the things that's happening too is that
as the,
as the High Iq tech geeks get a hold of
the world,
the demand for cognitive power is
increasing,
not decreasing,
right?
You want to be a teller.
Well,
you know those checkout machines,
they're not so simple.
You want to work at Mcdonald's.
You think that's a simple job.
You don't see robots working at
Mcdonald's and the reason for that is
that what Mcdonald's workers do is too
complex for for robots to do so
well.
So this is a discussion that no one
wants to have,
but that's okay.
It's still a problem and it has to be
dealt with.
So the US government,
I think I told you this at one point
already,
it's illegal to induct anyone into the
US army if they have an Iq of less than
83,
right?
It's about 10 percent of the population
because the US army and they'd be doing
Iq testing since Iq testing began
because they want everybody they can
possibly get into the army because in
peace time they use it as a way of
moving people up the socioeconomic
ladder and in war time.
Well obviously you need as many soldiers
as you can get your hands on and so
you're not going to be any pickier than
you have to be.
So when the U,
s army says it's illegal to induct
anybody into the armed forces.
If they have an Iq of less than 83,
then you know that they've done it for
absolute necessity.
Right?
And when people have made a finding that
contradicts what they want to hear and
they're doing it out of absolute
necessity,
you can be reasonably true that it's one
of those facts that just won't bloody
well go away.
And so you might think,
well,
if there's nothing for someone with an
Iq of less than 83 to do in the army,
what makes you think that there's
something that they can do in the
general population?
And then the issue is because the
Conservatives will say,
well,
they should just work harder.
It's like,
sorry,
that ain't gonna fly.
And the liberals will say,
well,
there's no difference between people
anyhow and you can just train people to
do everything and that's wrong.
So they're both wrong and they're
seriously wrong.
And the fact that neither side of the
political perspective,
we'll take a good cold hard look at this
problem means that we're going to
increasingly have a structural problem
in our societies because we're
complexifying everything so rapidly that
you can't find employment unless
increasingly,
unless you're intelligent,
you guys are really going to face this.
You know,
lawyers are disappearing like mad.
And the reason for that is you can look
it up online.
Increasingly.
You can do things yourself if you're
smart.
And so like the working class people
have been wiped out pretty nicely over
the last 30 years by by automation and
various other things.
It's the low end of the white collar
class that's coming up next.
So I'm not saying that lawyers lawyers
are in the low end,
but low end lawyers are in the low end
of the white collar class.
So there's still going to be plenty of
positions for people who are creative
and fast on their feet and super smart.
In fact,
those people are going to have all the
money that's already happening to a
great degree,
you know,
because if you're smart and you can use
a computer,
you're so smart.
It's just absolutely unbelievable.
Right.
And if you can't use a computer and lots
of people,
and I don't mean,
you know,
you can open word that isn't what I
mean.
I mean maybe,
I mean you can program and if you can't
program while you're right at the next
and so if you haven't got that with you,
you're,
you're gonna be left behind.
Oh,
lot of them will take demerol.
That's what's happening in the United
States.
Yeah,
it's an opiate.
Yeah.
So there's a massive drug problem
emerging and.
Yeah.
No,
I'm telling you,
that is what's happening there.
Yes.
Drugs.
Yeah.
Drugs of abuse.
Well,
that.
What is happening to a large degree is
people drop out of the employment race.
They get very depressed.
They develop chronic pain problems,
especially if they're men,
because chronic pain and depression are
very much the same thing.
And then they subsist on opiates which
are subsidized by Medicaid in the US.
I'm not kidding about this.
This is exactly what's happening.
What,
what else is going to happen to people
for whom there is nothing to do.
They have a terrible time,
especially if they're conscientious.
That's a good question.
You know the Ai guys are pushing hard on
this.
Hey,
what's the biggest employment category
driver?
Think about it.
What's Tesla doing?
What are all the ai guys working on as
fast as they possibly can?
Driverless cars,
no problem.
Except that's the biggest employment
category for men.
So what are those guys going to do?
Yeah,
they're going to sit home and be
miserable with their wives and take
opiates because they have chronic pain
problems,
right?
Nasty,
and you might think,
well,
could they think of something else to
do?
Well,
if you have an Iq of 83 or less,
you're not going to be doing a lot of
thinking about something else to do.
You know?
That isn't how it works because you're
more of a.
you're an act person,
not a thinking person,
roughly speaking,
you know,
and so if you have a task at hand,
especially if you're conscientious,
you can diligently go about it,
but you know,
I've tried to train people with Iqs of
80 and less to do what I would consider
tasks that,
that,
that one of you could learn to do in 10
minutes and never make a mistake again.
And it's like tens of hours with bare
minimum mastery of the tasks.
So it's ugly situation,
no doubt about it.